you know babies squarespace.com promo
code Hannibal do it that is promo code
Hannibal for 10% off your first purchase
do it get a website
[Music]
and Sweden you'll be a China
you know which cover hey how's it going
everybody hands around the podcast
episode mm-hmm I'm Hannibal Burres tony
trim we waiting on our guests I guess is
just walking into the up to the house
right now is we overslept welcome our
special guests and college friends open
mike eagle matt the levels is not good
how about that the level is good good
speech volume how's it going man it's
going right man
sorry we wasted some of your time sorry
mister were you leaning into the
doorbell
nah hell nah I wasn't just out no cuz it
was like you know why folks walk around
down the street man I'm looking like I
don't belong out here
you know how ring a couple hit the phone
you know I mean yeah I'm out what time
were you here I got here to 10:00 we was
well oh [ __ ] yeah that was we go early
this week I would have an early nice
week doing work and [ __ ] whatever man it
doesn't matter we are last night not
even that hard
no a lot of drinks
amongst the lord if you is any phrase is
that something people say
amongst the lord no no you know you just
throw stuff in see what sticks
okay I won't you know I just got to know
cuz I'll [ __ ] real start saying [ __ ]
you know
you should just say stuff minute yeah
just gonna say stuff with confidence you
see who the president is
yeah I guess say stuff dad dad dude
did you see what he did today today
today oh no I mean you know they had
this national National Prayer Breakfast
things were supposed to be important
yeah he roasted all Schwarzenegger had
the prayer breakfast I saw a headline
that he brought up Celebrity Apprentice
it was too petty you should have ever
seen in my life he said pray for Arnold
Schwarzenegger because the ratings is
low on the apprentice now TV raid he's
on a show he's executive producer oh
yeah keeping it in the news Wow as the
[ __ ] president it's wait man
you the pettiest
[ __ ] I've ever heard of yeah and
I thought I was patty actually Tom I
told him I patty down I've been taking
these weed pills lately and I've been
very mellow don't try me - we build we
build rats
oh we pills dibianco collateral I think
he'd be on coke oh he doesn't coke vibe
there's his Twitter account called Trump
regrets
yes II meant what people I love it sweet
about I voted for you
but you crazy as [ __ ] I regret and so it
just tweets all the people you retweets
here retweets all the people that talk
about voted for Trump that regret it now
lots of tweets like everybody know you
were gonna do this [ __ ] because I think
even even even me watching it I remember
thinking oh this is just his campaign
and he'll tone down if that's in a small
chance he becomes president oh your tone
down then he became president oh yeah
he's about that action [ __ ]
amania he about that [ __ ] action I
wonder what it's like being in his brain
what is a maniacs
a maniacs brain a seventy-year-old
maniac that's addicted to social media
and cocaine
the cocaine SEO and grabbing a [ __ ]
Nestle's in his three days you think if
there was a drug test on Donald J Trump
that I think his blood percentage is 100
percent cocaine a hundred for sick okay
he drinks cocaine water all day he is
cocaine personified ooh yeah he's a
petty cocaine I think I think that's who
you
he's like sneezes Oh yuck yeah he's so
gross man he was permanently sweaty and
orange and gross yeah like yeah the
weird circles around his eyes and the
orange Ness yeah it's like his eyes are
like there's no cure for that open the
clothes at the same time yeah that's
really weird
yeah he's hard to look at close gusted
man well yeah I don't like him being
president for one cuz I actually enjoyed
him as host of The Apprentice that means
really he was he was in today yeah he
wasn't ready for this [ __ ] you know he
wasn't ready to do this I think he
talked all that [ __ ] and at the end of
the day he's just trippin like he
doesn't no idea how to do this like he's
got all his people like lying on a
paperwork for the cabinet positions and
[ __ ] like he desiring them for a regular
job yeah just put you put you you know
you got an MBA from Harvard
don't check you know to me and all of
them are lying and it's like oh I
thought this is this is what we do right
now yeah well we're enough you know
ain't no Bill Maher I know Trevor Noah
I know Gilbert Godfrey it's Gilbert
Gottfried I hear talking [ __ ] I'm just
Gil forgot me can [ __ ] around beat a
Democratic candidate if you talk [ __ ]
like Trump do he's around the same age
you know me da man how's it going Mike
oh I'm chillin man yeah and my world is
crazy but I'm telling ya man where's
your well crazy I don't know uh I mean
I'm I'm in yo dumbass world now and
don't unknown I mean the artists like
this weird TV shades combat juggling
world
the combat juggling world that's my
world Oh see I know I wasn't knowing I
didn't know which world she was talking
about I missed them tweets man i N I
didn't some all in the combat job does
that mean you just hit people with
bowling pins or something like what is
the hand of juggling you try to keep
your [ __ ] gone by bumping into people
that's tight I'm that in their world but
I want to be a part of it I think you
can start down just putting the fillers
out okay yeah I'll watch that is online
it is yeah
that's a it's a real world combat
juggling okay yeah
is that like competitive tickling I'd
like that type of [ __ ] all right
isn't that doesn't have that creepy like
you know you don't have to do it under
false pretenses right hey you uh come by
for this combat juggling documentary I
won't touch you I still haven't seen it
psycho documentary man I want to hear
just great juggling is for real oh [ __ ]
what you thought you Google in Google so
man so you in you in the TV world you
know I'm in the back part where's all
the dumb ass meetings and I'm seeing how
people buy ideas and [ __ ] and that's
yeah you know I mean like walking in
rooms with just like a couple words on
the paper and network being like yeah
I'll pay a lot of money for that
like really it's that how does dumb and
[ __ ] works oh yeah wait what are these
meetings about what do you mean yes
hitch means show you what you what you
were I have no idea what you've been on
uh I mean a lot of this [ __ ] ain't
public record
yeah even look at general okay TV show
yeah I mean and I'm working on [ __ ] you
know me but it's all like behind the
scenes they no announcements been made
about that yeah cuz it's all in like
okay I got like a script it digging this
like in the like you don't I mean like
we're we're trying to do like a cartoon
or a sitcom or what you--what are you
yeah one's the script is show the psycho
single camp sitcom yeah um a comedy
showcase thing like I got a bunch of
ideas in like oh no I'm seeing now how
like
everybody's town sit around his town
yeah right yeah yeah what it seems like
all the networks hungry for just [ __ ]
people with ideas like they just like
they just not hearing a bunch of [ __ ] -
sounds creative so just about anything I
come up with I can get my age somebody
in yeah in the [ __ ] room you got
another sound so tragic when you put it
that way it was in Toledo and you like
son Toledo was Pat I did that so you
could have snacks that's right
I know my absence could be kind of wack
but I gotta spit these bars and get the
family on track no I got video for you
yeah I do it video man y'all gotta see
y'all gotta see Hannibal on his whole
rap presence the head shaking the eyes
closed over there but no I can't used to
try to battle me before he really said
words when he raps he's like look at me
Mike you felt it yeah before you could
see he was mumble rapping fit before you
know like not like the people do
professional yeah just like cuz he
didn't know how to say it worse so he
got example we had the Cajun citizenship
but he wasn't saying worse but he was
trying to come at me yes me so when at
what age do you think he realized what
you do and just process didn't
understood well he
we had him listening all kind of crazy
musically we can't we had we raised him
on like MF DOOM vast palaces and all
that type of [ __ ] and we've always had
like YouTube on a TV so we would show
him the videos you know I mean and then
we would go back to show him o try
videos a live videos and whatever you
want to see that was appropriate we show
him and so he came you know we showed
him my Shih Tzu yeah and and he got down
with some of that and so he used to
watch he we had a phase or like watching
my [ __ ] so I mean he knows that right
but now he knows it like I'm also not on
a radio so it's just another different
kind of thing you know what I mean it's
not like you know he knows I know bus
driver but he knows I don't know Big
Sean you know everything like that type
of like he's getting that all the
ecology right now is eight okay when you
we were hanging out a year or so ago you
said he requested a certain type of rap
yeah he calls it a beast to sound like
pop that's what he likes
yeah that's pretty like I say we raised
him on all this grimy [ __ ] yeah but I
think the first time he heard like it
was de sub this song that was
commissioned for the last Ninja Turtles
movie and it was like Juicy J and Wiz
Khalifa and somebody else yeah yeah he
heard that [ __ ] and he heard how clean
him high hats was and Cher and he was
like production I want more stuff like
this oh you [ __ ] with little yachty
in the audiophile you know I mean it was
it was on the Ninja Turtles yeah Juicy J
Wiz Khalifa and I forgot somebody else
on the song too so he put a clean
production or the actual he likes he
likes the beats where you can hear the
elements you know me was real clean he
wants to be on he wants to be on oh here
it is
shell shell shock shell shock knock
knock you about to get shelled I've
heard the song
yeah that's it it's a lot of noise
happening right now
sin-hye adds the energy he's like oh
yeah oh you know what no so cuz he
really liked that uh what was that song
at Harlem shake song remember that that
video craze yeah he was really into that
too so that might have been like he
might have went crossways in today oh
sure he's gonna be a TDM festivals in no
time
oh yo he got a little he got a little
keyboard setup with a little Mike gets
this little VTech toy I said I remember
he says he just be in it you know yeah I
remember you I had a setup for him with
a mic stand and some buttons yeah it was
[ __ ] with that that was way back when
he still had diapers on I remember that
yeah he tries to get down he don't care
about none of that now no more he's
strictly basketball now strictly
strictly basketball he was strictly
basketball videos he got hope in the
house niba trying to dunk on me
Oh like all day my dunk on your daddy no
you're not ever right there oh you
trying to give me if I'm going to
bathroom he try to like sneak up on me
really yeah he talk on his mom all the
time
she's just accepted she don't care like
I do yeah tell he will never in his life
dunk on me
ever ever don't care if he's six nine he
will never knock on me well you know
definitely without questioning I will
kidney punch him in the air he will
crumble if there's a referee I will get
thrown out of the game yeah yeah I'm not
having that
all right you know he's not getting that
on me he can hit you like that he can do
a lot in life you didn't ever don't call
me that's nineties that's me you grew up
on 90s basketball yeah ma'am no no easy
buckets never family or not no easy
buckets I respect it I've been dogged on
in my life let that has happened yeah
man when college plan yet the wrecks out
of the wreck like how wasn't quartz was
yeah
behind one of the dorms is foolishness
me Mike and Tony all went to the same
College Southern Illinois University in
Carbondale Illinois your mam yeah
good times good times sunday school
sessions how did you are link cause
y'all link through it was a call culture
here's coach at first
and that kind of morphed into Sunday
school yeah yeah cuz Coco stopped doing
that was so so culture was like same
thing basically it was exact same thing
and it was at her house for yeah ever
yeah yeah yeah then she we you know
decided to go and have a family and [ __ ]
that's right those factors she stopped
letting random [ __ ] in her apartment
and then yeah then you started yeah she
did it on Thursdays right I think it was
yes she did her Thursdays and then I did
it in Sunday so totally used to hosted
over Mike at his house poetry music
comedy everything Mike used to perform
yeah there other people performed there
well Mike Mike hosted it when you were
out for the summer
oh yeah he was you're standing remember
dumb well who was their host before he
was a whole stated before you were
hosting it but I showed I wasn't no oh
uh Katie cuz that was he showed up his
friends he was hosted case Haiti hosted
the original and then you came in and
took over and then in the summer you
were back in the shy and it like you
took over we went the long branch yeah
you know so it was like a a morphing
thing any time I was ever in one of
those I was hired of my mind
I don't know radio everybody was yeah
well when we went to Long Branch that's
when its sobered up yeah cuz we were all
presentable and [ __ ] they don't have
they don't allow alcohol in there cuz
it's like with their Sufis and [ __ ] so
they don't you know drugs or anything
zile upstanding and watered down it was
that was yeah it changed when we were so
the Open Mic started in Tony's bedroom
and it would be about 15 20 people or
something yeah and then it got too big
for the bedroom eventually moved to the
living room and it was in the living
room for a while how to run their people
we hanging out some people popping their
heads in the window this mix of stuff
Tanner and then it got too big for the
live in any move to a proper venue Long
Branch coffee house in Carbondale how
long did it stay in Long Branch I think
that's run time I left yeah it we did it
at Long Branch for
like probably like a little less than
like probably like five six months it
just kind of died down from there but I
was gonna say when did you leave
Carbondale and 2004
I left 2004 - yeah you in grad school I
did a year of grad school but I was I
was doing work for its education what
does that mean that was the program you
can gain and without having to take no
tests oh if you just kind of walk in
that's it but it was the words I don't
know how you got through school was part
cuz you were out there partying with us
I was but you were sent out [ __ ]
pledged and I did all yeah and I was all
right all kind of [ __ ] homecoming king
that's right god damn it
I did everything straight A's that's
crazy oh yeah I got kicked out a no foul
so I popped out yeah got a kick out I
sped up got kicked out for selling pot
yeah did you did you that you just
permanently out know what a suspended me
but it was like it was off campus ground
so like just on my own ship but remember
they put on that conduct the conduct
rule kind of co yeah yeah that [ __ ] so
it fell under the Conduct code so they
found out about and they try to get me
to snitch damn so they brought me into
the campus they brought me into the
campus interrogation room
there's the campus interrogation yes yes
the puede [ __ ] Carbondale it's the car
it's the SIU police station you know
they got their own police so they
brought me in there instead of the car
vanilla Saluki patrol exactly and then
they brought the [ __ ] Dean and then
the Dean came in as like a look man he's
like I know you only got a few few
credit hours left because like you don't
want to leave like this man give me some
may put out a pad a pen give me some
names let's make this and some like the
worst television show ever
yeah whose cat and snitch though I got
that degree you know the drug game the
carbondale was [ __ ] real man like
people used to get beat up and kidnapped
and yeah I wasn't on that [ __ ] horses
[ __ ] nap yeah yeah
yeah no only got go home you got kid now
yeah it was it was a wild [ __ ] going on
down there was some hood [ __ ]
and and it was people that was really
trying to pretend to be her once they
got down there they'll get caught up in
some real [ __ ] man my homie one of my
frat brothers got killed behind that
[ __ ] down here for real yeah you know
you remember King King John King yeah
yeah John Candy King I think so he used
to come to the spices [ __ ] his brother
his brother got killed down there behind
some drugs [ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah his brother
I know there was like I know
[ __ ] were going to the east
side of Carbondale all slinging crack I
did that for a fact and it was linking
up with castle mr. dowlas house and all
my roommates I was living with that one
guy would come in there they would have
like meetings in their 20 year old boys
there was a dark side to the [ __ ] it was
all just classrooms and [ __ ] poetry
sessions there was some dark [ __ ]
[ __ ] from Chicago yeah didn't
didn't have no business in college st.
Louis you know taking everyone yeah and
people was really turning to [ __ ] dorms
into the projects of [ __ ] that's just
straight out cast around that time I
remember because my GPA was horrible
coming out of high school I'm like [ __ ]
accepted me I guess I'm going to college
exactly I graduated with a 1.9 GPA and
then yeah like a 2/3
you know I mean I just did good on my a
CT and [ __ ] so yeah yeah that's exactly
how I got into yeah I totally [ __ ] off
in high school high school this podcast
spawns about [ __ ] is good if your high
school [ __ ] you if you if you in high
school
[ __ ] that
Highschool use promo code [ __ ] high
school forever to get 20% off all the
[ __ ] that you'd give to high school
and then you could delete the rest of
those [ __ ] check it out
use promo code Rambler that [ __ ] high
school this would hide future song plays
right gotta be some [ __ ] school yeah
yeah what's it what's your favorite song
that you've made of yours oh oh oh no
[ __ ]
probably the song guy called dishes is
about washing the dishes I really like
that song I like that's one of my
favorites is dishes yeah man I really
went someplace I don't even know how to
get back there but I really really it
was literally just about washing dishes
yeah it was about the [ __ ] I would think
about while I was watching ah
so like you know nummy yeah you know
that's I like that because I I wash
dishes I'm a weirdo like that I wash the
dishes sometimes it's just for the
meditative quality okay yeah so that's
what are you talking about yeah
brilliant this is the whole the whole
thing is just like a whole long stream
of consciousness like I was thinking
about it while I was doing the dish I'm
like I mean so you kind of freestyle the
[ __ ] I mean not really like just kind of
taught us some idea points while I was
washing dishes
me I'm just washing dishes you know bus
success that's what a house husband does
with the without the industry bus
there's no Forks left and I found some
pleading with some forceps I wish I had
a Corvette and like a killer Africa
because rap fables and happily Hitler
after their boss still a bachelor
wicked Willis - urban there's no grass
head Cole - liver cancer
no clogged drains of broken dog chains
no fault rain and black belt ball games
I waited all day til the time was right
I let the Sun fade not when it's shining
bright I don't like what my voice was
doing right there yeah but but the
concept and execution was great did you
did you like freestyle most of that or
was that not it how did you do that what
you know how you can like start writing
with the idea and just kind of just
start yeah connect and die so it's not
freestyle like going in to the booth and
just rapping but like kind of free
writing got you know I mean I'm glad you
figured that [ __ ] out cuz I remember
warmer in college you were a [ __ ]
monster on the Freestyle yeah I couldn't
I couldn't and you couldn't write well
it's not you know what I couldn't do I
couldn't record Oh like I could kind of
right yeah I didn't know I don't know
how to like write for breath pauses and
[ __ ] yeah yeah I would just like be
sound and [ __ ] crazy yeah I remember
cuz cuz I'd be like you have any songs
yet just freestyle they're know you know
you know if you remember them spare
parts dude yeah yeah yeah so I did my
first show yeah with then because it was
like we want to bill you yes you got to
do a set yeah and then I had to write a
bunch of songs but I made songs I had
that I didn't had no song and remember
five songs yeah I like to have some [ __ ]
to do
yeah can they pay me and it was the best
[ __ ] Finch I'm hanging out yeah
what do you remember one of the song
titles out of that first fight a to be a
to be a to be was one keeping it simple
yeah super villainy was another one
oh [ __ ] and that's all bust down I used
to do I think that's I'm song about
credit cards or something I think that
was a to be cuz it yeah
hey to be with these unpaid credit cards
yeah man you just gave me I'm triggered
right now oh yeah that's a PTSD [ __ ]
like yeah imma a college credit card
debt man oh dude he still that predatory
on college campuses that's just so yeah
help do it I signed up for life some
sunglasses system [ __ ] yeah like a free
t-shirt yeah we got a free t-shirt that
[ __ ] they used to be in front of Feiner
like saying do they still do that [ __ ]
at colleges I said it was super wack I
feel bad that should definitely be bet
not on the campus like right in the
cafeteria offering people with no income
credit and I would go into the Student
Center and buy McDonald's with my
[ __ ] credit card a so far now
fits and timberlands and all types of
dumb [ __ ]
fresh it [ __ ] college dances the barn
confetti flat definitely had a
confederate flag and it was definitely
the only place black people with kick it
is so weird and it was like 10 miles
away in the country as [ __ ] and we use a
literal barn right it was barn
Mike explain what the barn is I mean it
was a it was a barn with electricity and
then they would have a DJ and some trash
cans and a little bar and we would all
go kick it there yeah that was the only
place I ever remember passing out yeah
like I I literally woke up with my head
in a trash can that Fred's barn like I
was just like throwing up and fell
asleep there it's like wait it was
really doing because here's the thing
I'd never been to the barn I was invited
to the barn a few times I was even
actually invited to DJ there once but I
just never do I never took it but never
once at a bar never been to the barn why
I've been to players ball but that's
when they moved it from the barn to like
some other Sports Center yes support
center and I say yeah but never been to
the barn only because all you had to say
to me was it's 10:00
there's a Confederate flag hanging above
everyone I'm like yeah I'm not gonna go
to that I had been there like three
times before I even heard that
Confederate flag [ __ ] I think he used to
cover it up or something one time I was
in or not yeah and they were like there
be fights there like y'all weekend's I'm
right here dude I was out but somebody
started shooting like any yeah so why
would I want to be there I'm like I'm
not going to the bar so I do get hit
with a bottle effort like really like he
was trying to stop a fight and some
other dude just came across and smashed
him here it was a bottle oh it was a
horrible place why were we there that
was a horrible I mean the Sports Center
was like in the realm of like the
universe it's like it's like we're bad
people great website this looks lik step
up your business and put my money your
pocket more food on your family's table
more gifts for your girl and for your
parents and you wanna like buy those
curtains you're always been looking for
it you got to step your web presence up
go to squarespace.com put in promo code
promo code
Hannibal and you can get 10% off your
first purchase Squarespace they make it
simple for you you can do it even if you
stupid and if you're smart too
then you think this is great I'm not
using my brain power on this I could do
other things like solve stuff you know
what to do get a website squarespace.com
Squarespace
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this is virtual reality game called
drunken bar fight it's just that we have
bottles on the bar you can drink what
you get stronger as you drink you up and
then if you want to kick off the fight
you just throw a bottle at somebody and
then they start coming towards you yeah
you try to how do you how do you play
this it's virtual reality like you got a
helmet you got one of them no oh but I
want one
that's a great workout yeah like
fighting in the club just great game for
the kids
oh yeah did you get into any fights in
carbondale no but I play it and I was
just like walking into a fight all
skyfirst invited stupid did you did you
have to go through something like
vigorous yeah it's awesome
yeah it was stupid all of this don't I
love you get paddle in the ass I don't
know what you're talking about
so what was it like man what was that
like walk us through it man [ __ ] that
was started by a bunch people with some
really good ideas yeah all the time
it got infiltrated by [ __ ] yeah and
all of the original teachings just like
gangbang and how like all that [ __ ]
originally looked like some positive
initially and then you know people get
it and they get the symbols but they
don't get to actual teachings and it's
just like all that type of [ __ ] it just
falls off after a while but the dance
stupid I do I do like astrology so
strongly reinvigorated my whole college
party life does not have something to do
yes
doing the party that was a big deal were
you there what happened member of the
pikes
the Pikes got disbanded cuz they killed
one of their members there any hazing or
something and I remember that seems I
haven't so often yeah that's right but
with them like they made him like swam
across like at night drunk they made him
like swim across some lay around to some
Shane just drown and then they're like
yeah you guys know more yeah they used
that people used to die from drinking
too much water pledging that's crazy
yeah it's not that serious yeah find a
video game you're some fans like find
the television show yeah you're like a
weekly lunch or dinner ritual yeah and
do that with friends get the same jacket
and you can do a dance with you know
what happened with me man what else
would you like okay well my position on
campus as the outsider poetry dreadlock
dude I was doing I was anti everything
and then you have your I remember you
had your like little nerdy section I had
my folks man we all used to get down and
kick in an ear and all of that we have
the community but I [ __ ] around it got
like a close to a couple dudes and a
frat and they're like oh it started
looking like they knew some [ __ ] you
know I really like it started like they
you know and I mean like they all look
like they they got some you know what I
mean and I just be around and see like
damn like what because I said then I
started paying attention to people who
was just you know regular campus people
and they were playing something I'm like
damn different now like I mean did they
approach you or well yeah like I got
asked but then I was interested because
a couple of the homies we used to rap
with was was in it and I didn't know it
yes oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] you know and I
kind of just got caught up in and all
that way and went down that path and
like I got friends forever from that
[ __ ] like cuz you go through some [ __ ]
so I got I got like real homies yeah for
life out of that [ __ ] but what I'll
heard about me I like them dudes I don't
like nobody else in my fraternity around
the world that I mean
I was coming with a couple of them I
have an experience I came here and went
to some schools and looked like yeah
yeah damn they might come looking for
you after they hear you know what strip
me of my membership I paid no dues in 15
years
dudes I'll remember nineteen dollars and
six cents hey what the [ __ ] does that
been you gotta pay it's a national
organization like they have structure
they have conventions they have like all
type or like official [ __ ] so you I paid
like fees yeah you pay dues annual fees
yes
in the hundreds I don't remember how
much is applicable ooh I have not paid
in a long time I'm not like officially
I'm not a member no more because I'm not
financial but if what's the benefit of
being a member like boys you give jobs
yeah exactly like a you if you're
working in corporate America there's a
lot of inroads that she could make for
you like if you see your brother in a
position where you can hire people he'll
put you on the only me like that should
meet somebody [ __ ] a rap for living
[Laughter]
unless Big Sean was your brother yeah
but he messed up see most other rappers
is younger than me because they waste
their time going to college doing all
that [ __ ]
nice oh that yo I had a friend of mine
uh old friend of mine that grew up on
the same block as me mm-hmm
and he wrote me he texted me
HB trying to come to the rap game mm if
you can help me anything you put my
music in the right hands or just
introduce me so some people I say it was
you got what you got a soundcloud you
got Twitter Instagram
ain't no mm what the [ __ ] do you want me
to what do the manjit's like what are
you talking about he in a year
who's like where the [ __ ] is the music I
was really upset I didn't have a problem
putting like tweeting a link or even
putting it if it's a good song if he's
good then putting it as a part of
Instagram video or something and tagging
but he had nothing I could only imagine
the leaps in logic that people do when
they send you [ __ ] I could only imagine
it's just any like you don't I mean
anybody like even me like there's people
that reach me to reach him me too you
get the stand of oh no I will not get
this to animal [ __ ] ask me can i hook
up meet-and-greets way no yes it's
really yes I don't know but it's it
shows you some about people yeah last
night we went to Roca can I talk about
this with what the rogue that rogue is
show at the ice house sure yeah and
there was this there was this crazy late
when we walked in he was taking a selfie
with this lady
and she would just she just started like
she started talking he's right about to
go on a stage or he was about to like
switch up and she just kept talking and
I look at Joe Rogan's face he shoots me
this look like what the [ __ ] is lady huh
so he just kind of pieces like I'm gonna
go over there and he just walks to
another room
so I go outside to have a cigarette
later on and she comes out and she sits
right next to me and just starts talking
some crazy yeah I've never seen fans on
this level like she was just like she's
like she said why are you out here do
you know you don't respect Joe Rogan oh
I'm having a cigarette I'm just chilling
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
she's like she's like I love everything
about him I you know me and my boyfriend
are a big fan so she's going on about
him and then she starts talking about
lines she's like but I don't wait in
lines I'm from Newport Beach and I don't
wait in lines I don't care about seats
and I don't know why all these people
are tripping but Joe Rogan's awesome but
I wouldn't wait in a line for and she's
just like I'm like where are you going
with this like she's like but it was a
weird kind of fandom cuz you could see
it in her eye like and
hambo talking about it like that guy
clocked in like seven hundred episodes
of podcast so he's probably embedded in
that woman's brain what a weird way yeah
but it was like I mean I'm seeing I'm
seeing it you know what I mean I've seen
I've seen a low-grade of it just in my
[ __ ] you see how people can form ideas
about you and bring them to your show
yeah
project all that [ __ ] on you yeah I
don't I mean but I can only imagine
somebody just like hella more popular
it's probably way [ __ ] worse cuz you
got that yeah and you got headphones on
so it's like it's like your monologue
turns into their inner monologue your
arms and so it's like it's like he was
screwy bro it's a little scary none none
none seen him and I said I could only
imagine the leaps and logic and yeah
just fantasies [ __ ] live in and
reach out saying anything yeah yeah it's
weird one thing people DM me dreams of
there's that I was in I dreamt that you
were they just tell ya you were [ __ ]
and my mom was are you supposed to
respond to that okay don't you thought
you want to hear this my friend dreamt
that he was hanging out with you y'all
had a good time
just thought you would want to know no
that's a compliment people you got your
people drink juice up kinda weird ass
compliments compliments on a compliment
well there's a thing I think people feel
like they have to say everything so
people when sometimes they could just
just not say that there's one girl I
took a set of pelicans game two years
ago in New Orleans and second quarter we
sittin in great seats in the [ __ ] and
she says I have to tell you something
I'm thinking about to say oh I had
chlamydia
she said my ex-boyfriend was a huge fan
and I used to suck his dick while we
listen to you come oh why would she
further and all it hurts my head and I
said you didn't have to say that at all
and then you had to sit through the rest
of the game next door well you know what
you know what happened is that actually
the seats that I bought were seats that
it was one seat in front of the other
seats Oh perfect there were seats next
to her so I was sitting next to her the
top but then after she said that I kind
of sat in my product just like rural
rules can't be that that there's no
amount of liquor should know that's
that's excusable to say people say weird
[ __ ] get in yeah you know what was she
trying to accomplish
no she's probably just she was you know
what she was she was thinking out loud
that's all she's doing I don't know what
the goal was there was like you got you
don't want to talk about how Anthony
Davis is destroying Greg money he was
killing Greg it was distance dog oh man
Greg Monroe couldn't do nothing that day
it wasn't Andre Drummond Holmes he
baller I think driving was doing all
right but uh let's talk about what's
going on in this girl's head it was a
bit of a mess man do you when do you
make songs in a car you know your time
to make is it natural you say trying to
make a song pretty teeth like I'll have
to like decide to turn a podcast off cuz
I need to [ __ ] be productive ha yeah
and I'll put on a beat and try to find
yeah yeah yeah it's yeah life is so
distracting these days is hard to just
find a fine time to like cuz you're like
I gotta catch up on this TV show this
Podcast well so so what will I mean I
know all of them have different origins
likely so just say a anxiety siggy
starfish yeah one of my favorites how
did that like walk me through that
unprocess I said would that be for like
a month
yeah and it was one of them ones where
like well good either that or just in
the phase I was in at the time like I
really needed a hook first so I just
start writing mm-hmm wait that's that's
produced by golden panda yeah or gold
panda uh-huh that's a good be yeah yeah
okay go ahead yeah yeah he's don't man
um funny thing about that beat though
man yeah like that be kind of just like
fell in my lap yeah I don't know if I
ever would have picked it be tomorrow
yep you know what that beat is funny cuz
I when I spin it in the set sometimes
it's funny like in the beginning when I
blend it it like falls off of the
measure somehow but kind of pulls itself
together is weird and like it's not like
it's not a standard like yeah I know
exactly what you mean by that it's it's
it's it's a hard beat to spend so I'm
guessing it's a heart beat the rap oh
well you know it's just honestly I tend
not to pick Beach the people like I
guess yeah in general I like good beat
though I mean but what I'm saying is
like like poppy beats are saying exactly
like it Debbie on his own doesn't do the
things that I usually look for a beat to
do and I was able to find something in
that beat that I could connect to you
know something I want to do with it yeah
and you know luckily that came across my
lap because it was that's a big song
from yeah you know what I mean yeah cuz
go pad is pretty big yes he is and he's
good at what he does just make [ __ ] that
moves people but I tend to look for like
a lot of melody yeah and sometimes if
I'm looking more towards that side of
the spectrum you don't get a beat just
like open yeah I mean
[Music]
[Laughter]
lamb is some place I've never been
Yetta can straight up a better man if I
play like the Astra to come around
never handy could be sagacious and most
times in my hand these old school let it
man
if apparently that has to be noted color
gets enhanced and better control the
tank won't give like daggone lift but
you did a good job doing this one live
you did it or not yeah yeah that was
about today man
I had on a weird shirt a my hair to know
what I want to do yeah and the
Thundercat was behind you on the base
that [ __ ] was dope
it looked open and you sounded good
thanks man yeah that was a great moment
I was hot on Twitter for like two weeks
Hospital yeah I'm sure it was a big bump
national TV yeah I started seeing a
sauce out of Twitter that day random to
randos yeah oh yeah yeah oh yeah no I
haven't I haven't wit I haven't felt
that yet but I see it cuz I see my
homies getting doing their thing and and
then I see the waves come out of the
waves of yeah like that last time you
are Rogan like isalways Hey yeah yeah I
still see it sometimes I'm like man that
[ __ ] is not going anywhere Crosby
lingers yeah and eggs just be saying
whatever leg like whatever it was just
say the craziest [ __ ] did you let it get
to you or have you figured out a way
cool but see my [ __ ] is real cure a to
do with my follower count it's cold but
it's not like super huge yeah people
[ __ ] with me they [ __ ] with me and
usually people that don't [ __ ] with me
they know they're not like angry about
me typically yeah but when I get a look
like that you know I mean like a
national TV look you know people with
more celebrity retweeting so you're
getting in front of people that's when I
see like that other side yeah yeah yeah
it's their life welcome to the life
nation-state I'll stay and II don't know
man yes they Andy with mine yeah you
know low stakes so you're looking to do
you're not gonna get on the TV screen
though ya know another this is going
down well when did you really say oh I
need to yeah this is new news to me to
write something or did somebody would
did you have the idea that does somebody
say come in
give me a name
and then it's their name you like yeah
that's me anything what do you got
exactly that that should happen for two
years Getty workout [ __ ] all the time
you game yeah we we got em we got ahold
of the thing that we have somebody write
with me and him who is some [ __ ] we can
see where it goes Patti is also another
guy that went to college with us and you
guys made what was album called you can
get that album you guys know where is
the weirdest [ __ ] ever bless my heart
though that's what Dave was telling me
like that's or Gaddy Serengeti was
telling me that that's a one and done
deal like you guys we did in a tour in
the states that we did a tour Europe on
and then we retired yeah and that's it
right my favorite track off of that was
was that is this right here this one
right here
zorak we see you wheeze the end the show
with that song now it's proud of that -
he's all my beats yeah yeah this
reproduced every song lon
I lost Matt in that space beauty display
box case I agree piece named Susan
topical and transparent even like a
movie room drama in a coming-of-age
movie treat the ladies well warm chest
and a fuzzy and nobody just Matt just
come for like a hammock never change
baby right don't forget your turtleneck
it's cold like rain check being outdated
technologies I'm busy painting that's
good track yeah yeah good beats to our
surprises Mike's got some nice beat I've
been making fees for every Shabbat you
don't think it'd be so acid Pro bad no I
remember so with the who you working
with on the TV side um I got some [ __ ]
cooking with with Baron von like our
live show like that's looking like you
know that'll end up somewhere we have
Funny or Die on that script is [ __ ] I'm
working on working with a serious bids
at Purdue's at midnight on that and you
know and I got a working with - another
production company on stuff man like
like that's a he's a seems to be the
easy part you know I mean is is it's
linking up with the production company
he's getting behind idea and just
starting to develop it yeah but it was
just like you said do I think just like
people just seeing that our new comics
are hearing humor and my music and
probably like seeing my tweets and [ __ ]
they will bring me in for meetings yeah
just make rap music was just story okay
what is is that it LA think cuz I never
hear about my friends in Chicago feeling
like I kind of meeting it too in a
meeting it for like for what nothing
wasn't meetings well I mean I guess as
much as you know you want it to be you
know what I mean sometimes you just go
in meeting people I remember yeah
general meetings you just go in
yeah but if I'm have something then it
could be productively you see I got
seven ideas about here all seven of them
and I feel like you gonna like one or
two and then if they like that that you
can go forward it but sometimes just
meeting people and then you know getting
in front of their faces and then
do something they remember that they had
bottled water but but but these meetings
how often do ideas get stolen oh no
because like how can you even prove that
they like unless you recorded in a
meeting how could you even prove that
way like say you haven't brilliant idea
you right in there the more [ __ ] are
like right after the meeting like
there's your bottled water we got a show
to do guys like I haven't seen nothing
like that happen I mean but I'm new to
all this but like I'd see it see it
seems real honorable from what I've seen
and also I see when people submit [ __ ]
cold they usually got to like fill out
some type of paperwork
oh gosh so there's some kind of a
protection yeah yeah because yeah I
would I would think probably there's
just thievery left and right ideas is so
easy to steal you know la people never
have the same idea to toe yeah yeah you
know yeah that now started to be a lot
of comedies or movies with an uber
driver as the lead yeah cuz I said new
world for shows and [ __ ] I mean that
that's gotta be so [ __ ] complicated
as a comic to just be like wait a minute
is this a joke that I subconsciously
wrote because I've heard it somewhere
else like when you have to edit yourself
or just try to remember you how you came
up with it did you hear it from another
comic Yatta Yatta will yes sometimes
that happens we're the same way of
thinking about that it is it is tough oh
that's why I like telling straight-up
stories great ya know what's yours yeah
I was there yeah some saw that happened
to that person - fine but I'm net yeah
yeah that's a good that's a good way
that's a good strategy
yeah you know it's spitting bars and
spin bars
you good I like this yeah it's quiet
times I was just seeing what was gonna
happen not like yeah us and James Dean
you know I mean it's chilling James yeah
they Holly did they put the Hollywood
theme in this air B&B got Marilyn Monroe
over there I get the Rat Pack over there
it's good you got James Dean on two
spots very on the nose he was yeah only
live 24 2014 bags under his eyes serious
for 20 [ __ ] didn't he die in a car
accident like a horrific car accident is
that what happened I think so I think he
just yeah yeah he was like driving a
sports car and he just flew off the road
and crashed it he is I believe so in the
eyes of a 78 year old man yeah Tom Waits
in this movie he was cool dude though I
never seen was in a movie
I mean he was cool in his movies how did
he talk at his movies movie I've never
seen one neither no rebel without a
cause that was a good one yeah II didn't
man would it mad at his dad if some [ __ ]
the whole movie right yeah I just
remember like it I remember we studied
that movie in high schools was a long
time since I watched it but I remember
who you go to Fame main west and
desplaines
damn yeah I had movie class I mean it
was like yeah it was a it was cool nice
and we studied you know we studied rebel
without a cause but it was more about
like his acting style that was cool like
he like kind of like method acting
composing the style acting he did like
little things that made you know him
specifically a good actor I can't get
into specifics I'm not gonna try to act
like I'm smart
yeah but I'm taking a night to class no
yeah yeah what are you doing acting
class learn how to act I mean like like
like what what is a class like I've
undertaken a class at Leslie Caron
school yeah so Eric Andre yeah I'm you
know so you might have heard about it to
him alright but I don't know there's no
name to her technique way she's not met
or any any mother she's our own but like
what what do they say like bring
something out from your know this thing
is not that like what that it's very
technical so like whatever just learn
the words
learn your way they say like make I
don't make eye contact with the cat like
give me some um examples of like good
acting techniques okay like they're
teaching they taught us some [ __ ] like
called threading thread which is
important right like basically threading
is all that is [ __ ] that's not written
down if you think that character would
actually physically do to connect these
lines or these actions and the script
it's not necessarily on the page yeah
you know and so like nuances yeah so
sitting down and then like you know if
they're going to say this are they
crossing their legs first or are they
leaning in like yeah that's all the [ __ ]
that you have an actor you have to make
those choices actually mean I so like
it's ratings or some [ __ ] that they do
she's ready so all the all the aspiring
actors out there tell ready get your
threaten off no I don't throw it at all
no threaten for me you see the words for
no word that's it works of no words
watch my performances in daddy's home in
neighbors is works
silence words silence words silence what
song is one I love to solve but it
didn't connect with people as much as
you like um damn that's a good question
there's a song at the end that I album
rappers of died natural causes called
damn what is that song called
Reclamation's something spitted acapella
know how suede but um I thought that was
gonna be a big song yeah only like
people liked it Oh member reclamation
yeah I thought that was gonna be a big
one but you know I think I think all my
albums have a few of them where I'm like
yeah this one is Christmas
Oh 10 minutes know what okay now that
was a mistake I made cuz this is the
thing at the end of this there's
actually another song oh yeah you only
mean like it but the person who I had
layout the album with a foot after I got
mastered so they ascended into iTunes or
whatever yeah like I wanted them to just
make a hidden track so I'll just start a
meeting there they put like three
minutes of dead air holes between gear
but you can't do that
like Chancellor that is like that is
like if I'm going through my tracklist
and I see a Sun that's nine minutes I'm
like probably more likely to skip I want
to put nine hold on I think we get Nitto
think we're getting it there's a silence
[Music]
sounds good one of those ended album
songs and sounds like church
[Music]
anti-religious with shall we say me
[Music]
fools
though you got to go into iTunes like
Kanye oh no what'd he do he just chains
in it oh oh you can't do dental hide so
you could do that on tidal and [ __ ] yeah
you can't do that license did he do it
on so soon I think you just I think his
but but then he keep his old versions up
and then just put new versions up or
some choice which he just swears it out
well when you're Kanye you can do
whatever I got the cash a man I think no
I can't walk in there like that yeah
yeah they kicked me out the building you
know me
mm-hmm and they're making demands that
[ __ ] I can't get on my [ __ ]
front page when I album drop you know me
I can't even get in a little rotating
banner thing I've been getting pitch
they turned me down every time [ __ ] yeah
I mean yeah that is you got a UH
I don't know what you got do sell more
records
Sam well record store more no already do
no yeah you're on the road you travel
you DJ for yourself to widely last to I
had somebody with me but yeah mostly
yeah mom are you just travel solo right
which is [ __ ] stupid but it's but
your makeup you probably making so much
more money Evan at the Heller more money
yeah like that's why I last tour I
brought somebody with me and it wasn't
even so much for the stage it was just
someone be traveling even got anywhere
by myself yeah like I say where's on
yeah man absolutely like in your head
yeah man so different kind of loneliness
just do man on the road is so stupid
like what you're getting to check you
know this is smart you own that [ __ ]
airplane or in that hotel after the show
you like it's [ __ ] dumb like wait so
the merch so you you get offstage you
run over to the merch table so Jesus
Christ you can't do that to yourself you
gotta bring somebody I've learned you
know I just you know I got it's only a
few people in the world who I really
want to be around like that yeah yeah
that's true yeah yeah but you gotta have
a point like I used to bum around with
Getti getting no money but it was just
exciting
yeah it's getting such a good fun person
to be with so it's nice traveling around
handles not so bad either
I'm all over the place yeah yeah man
well thanks thanks for coming through
Mike good to see you thanks thanks for
having me man I mean I'll try to get a
welcome try to get yourself by acting
class tonight I'll be threading the
Chevy threatened but uh I'm hitch all
the path to see what's all wrong cool
yeah I'm good look on your pitches bro
appreciate hope it works out hope I see
you on TV next year I got an email to
answer right now Tim I had a key to my
[ __ ] future Nate hey that's
what my life is like right yeah
[Music]
[Music]